here is its massive bang like you could
imagine that if in the fight in the war
there isn't shooting like rifle - oh
nice
I hear this no it came out from my
bungalow and I prepare because I plan to
take the ferry back to Phuket at 11 o
clock so I get out immediately to look
and I saw this huge wave is about half
of the coconut tree is joining into me
right
oh and that noise and people scream and
I fell I close my eye I think I can't do
anything I did I sure I don't know this
that's the moment you know and what can
it Economo yeah it's towards me like
1015 meters it's come right there so I
just felt I remember this is 10 year
pass
and before I could not talk about it to
anyone because I fell it's too bad and
then I was on the tree I felt a frying
is this is why I cannot say to people I
fell like I did and I actually frying I
live my body you know I go over the
ropes and over the fish and with the
fence tall event and then to the trees
is it's just happened just murder I see
the second way because I own this will
become like come together like in the
middle res but when they go out fat
before gradually not as fascism at the
first one but then I don't know I I did
I saw the couple next to me they just
have their you know I didn't have
clothes on because they were sleeping
sleeping time for the tallest in hippie
island but lucky enough I get my
teachers and you know and my short and I
got my small R xx and in the [ __ ] tower
because our people had to you know leave
the moon glow to the boats to the furry
didn't have clothes on so they just have
like you know sleeping pants
the only sweetie with me they cry at the
lady cry and the man was happen I meant
the noise of what people is suffering
from the first wave come he's gone
disappear not so much so the second way
this actually is swallowed them so they
did I go I was I try to ask people to
help me to take this enjoy the people to
the house place we can leave them here
on dirt wash is the way up come back
again in the end so I didn't know what
to do he caught our people for help but
this one man told me often I'm stupid
but I should run to the high place
what are you doing here Sam your life is
you married one I said I don't know and
I said look if you're laying here them
choice
there are your mom your brother's he
said no but I feel sad for them just run
just go
you still prefer carry for ten years did
the corners he said I have to come and
I'll take charge I have to choose which
one to go first on the chopper that
moment is pregnant lady and it's very
leg broken best terrible wound that one
chopper I make decision I thought us
this pregnant lady shoes look a little
bit better than the other man so I said
that men go first and okay all of our
volunteer groups getting bigger when
when people see how people come to help
carries you know people I did hear after
Haiti and Captain come and tell me that
she could not make it she died I feel
bad this way I did one she can't make
this guy she died on her show